is this my controller are you okay there
you go
hey you know your classic color of blue
yeah you know me blue man there's lore
in this game
where two men fuse together and we have
to control a character
at the same time wait you mean you're
we're we're literally
uh my portrayal of septa player from
that one
uh markiplier tv we're left brain right
brandon
the [ __ ] cursed creation oh my god
oh my god kill me just like the day i
was born
no no
[Music]
it does look like the oh what oh god
oh it's like playing heave hoe all over
again yeah that's what i thought when i
saw it it was very heave hesk
but oh there you go oh okay
easy all right okay so grab all right
grab
oh i don't know where we're supposed to
go i'm not paying attention to
instructions can we climb
or dirty also we're oh also where are we
self-regenerating cells manipulate your
reptil what is that
oh we can scream at each other oh
oh my god okay
so we just talk until we explode great
was there any explanation as to where
we were probably
oh okay you mean you need an explanation
for this
i think it speaks for itself honestly
yeah yeah
it kind of looks like that thing that uh
your septica
thing is in you know a tank
okay i'm trying is this my arm which
one's my arm hold on let me
know this lord
there you go okay okay i'm the darker
arm
yes i think now i can't hear anything at
all all the sounds just went away
really yeah yeah i don't know what you
did but it went away
whoops that's okay maybe if i just
reconnect i i don't know
are we gonna have to go through the
intro again lore okay should we watch
this
well did you skip it last time yeah okay
okay
evil plebeians i really don't see how
this applies
to what we've already seen this relates
more to shrek than it does the game
we're playing
is that us i don't see how it could be
kind of separate you're not wrong
oh this oh yes
yes i'm pretty sure it had something to
do with inbreeding
uh that seemed to be the core of it you
know when a daddy
loves a mommy and a brother loves a
sister
and a cousin [ __ ] a dog you end up with
this
yeah oh my god i hate existence
i still don't even understand what the
actual controls game is
oh we're hector and achilles are you
sure
are we in our own head is this our head
i think we are
my hector am i achilles ah
why would we ever have to get rid of our
arms i don't know
just in case you never know i'm speaking
to you
[Laughter]
oh my god all right don't you miss 2016
youtube
yeah man is that what this is oh man
harley's like your head explodes
oh god and that's the audience's
reaction
yeah every time oh boy life beautiful
life
beautiful beautiful existence do you
think we can meet a
sweet lady i'll be glad if we meet
anything that doesn't vomit when it sees
us
okay you got sound now right i do have
sound yes i can hear it
for all the good it's gonna do me
because the party is downstairs baby oh
i can still yell at you
i think that's how we respawn
oh you're right oh [ __ ] oops
[Music]
how much pain are we in probably
all of it all the time are we gonna
what eat them [ __ ] them what are we
doing i don't know this is the prequel
to carrion
did you play that game i did like it
speak yeah
is it actually auto-tuned oh yeah
dj achilles on the mic congrats dave
17 years of work mark you got any words
uh
live life love life you love to live
life
party on you heard it here first folks
all right quick drop all right cool good
all right let's touch this place i
[ __ ] hate dave
yeah who's dave oh
oh it's married to a melder oh boy
here we go this is for us i can tell
because of the
flesh because nobody else would go into
this
even the whole doesn't want us thanks
buddy
it is kind of like carrion although
carrion's control scheme was elegant
uh i don't like it see there's a septic
eye oh
my friend oh okay your arm's gone oh if
you touch it it's your arm
no you're definitely not my fault
so why do we need to regenerate the arm
what is that all about what's the point
of that i think
i think if it gets stuck somewhere how
would it get stuck
yeah whatever you know no i don't make
video games i just yell at them
okay so we gotta all right we got this
oh
my god this is exactly like heave-hole
except the controls are just so much
stupider
so now we don't have weight to blame
yeah do we have a single bone between us
ah bones are for horses yeah you don't
need bones where we're going
hell who's crying is that a baby is that
a baby
ew oh yeah are you grabbing you grabbing
yeah
okay i think now you're grabbing abner
if i had one bone if i just had one you
think my arms get erect like a penis
you're just actually forcing blood in
and out of them at will
should we just call this video player
libs
okay up and over oh my god my arm is
that this is why
you can kill your arm because you don't
want to have it no because
i'm tucked in your armpit oh
yeah we're around each other okay there
you go there you go it's just not a lot
of muscle strength here all right i'm
gonna grab
a grab you grabbing excellent oh yeah
excellent see that yeah i saw it i wish
i didn't see it
all right oh this is just awful
this is you got it you got it i believe
it oh my god this is exactly the type of
control scheme that just is infuriating
oh yeah
cool okay mark don't throw a chair i
would never
oh my god okay up we go maybe
are we lighter if oh maybe we're lighter
one of us doesn't have an arm
wait no it's not like i can keep the arm
gone oh yeah we shouldn't touch that
thing
or should we i kinda wanna touch it no
that's definitely a death it's gonna
follow us in the
water oh yeah for sure
wait no i'm not i'm not i'm not down i'm
not down i'm not down there we go
you got it you got it oh okay you let go
this is a lot of trust going on here
okay here we go yeah
[Music]
okay hang on no hang on i'll swing i'm
gonna slap
just a little swing you got it there i
got it there you go
there you go okay ready we're getting it
we're getting it
okay there's a spike on that other one
okay we need to go like
okay just
no we're fine i think i [ __ ] it up no
you didn't because watch this
oh no oh my god perfect we're so good
we'll go under okay you swing let go of
your arm and go
yeah i got it good okay that is not what
i suggested but
you said swift ah that was your fault
okay
okay all right there's like some
momentum change if you delete your arm
there's like some kind of moment
momentum e
inertia yeah that the whatever that is
newton's law we're going under wow
that's terrifying are you seeing what
i'm seeing uppies
you see uppies uppies ah they're secrets
yeah sure let's go oh hey are you alive
you live not for long party cup oh we
can get it
beer pong oh totally worth it
the [ __ ] are they doing back there
multiple seizures standing
i have no idea i don't think we can go
right it looks like that's closed off
oh also what if we climb across the roof
here like if we climb laundry
i don't know yeah
suck our dick do we have a dick we have
two things that are basically like dicks
uh
suck on those ow take one of these
i pressed the wrong button it worked out
all right this is all good okay okay i'm
gonna grab
and you let go [ __ ] it
this is like sharing one brain yeah well
no we got two
we saw songs no no no no
hey why don't i go here you saw it you
you you saw it and you went for it i
know
man this is why i am known as the good
one
this is why i'm right brain yeah wait
which one's the logical brain
uh right brain is
is feeling who [ __ ] knows i don't
think any of that's actually
what did we just do kill up oh well
that's a problem
okay that lady just jumped off of real
free will yeah that was not us
and that baby wait they're going to fall
on us
i called it jesus okay no not yeah
good now we have to avoid being always
upset
okay this doesn't seem run
get out of here skrillex okay i don't
like that we're getting
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
we're trapped
the arms are fine the arms are fine yeah
arm's hat get that hat
let me get ah okay sorry sorry
you had to get the hat what i mean i
don't have a hat anymore
why did we hit this [ __ ] button i
don't know did we have to hit the button
maybe we didn't actually have to hit the
button
oh [ __ ] we're good we're good yeah we're
good oh they're gone
they actually died consequences for our
actions
wait regrow regrow please there we go
jesus
anymore go yeah go are we going are we
doing it oh
what's up ginger coming through oh no
no no no come through we should have
gone for it
you're right we should have gone for it
what if what if all we do is roll it
seems like that might be actually more
effective
that might be the tactic except uphill
except uphill except uphill
we block it we can block it i'll block
it i'll save it
i exposed us red light green line green
light
i have no arm grow it back please oh
[ __ ] oh wait we're good
all right excellent okay it's okay arms
are dead weight
you don't need them i i can't wait for
level three of this game when we unlock
the erect feature it's really going to
change up the game here
we'll hit the viagra upgrade oh yes
please this is a science lab they have
to have some here
late night regret department this is
where the viagra is
wow that time to swim
uh you know i was joking about the whole
upgrade thing but i think if we were to
jump in a vat of radioactivity that
should
probably upgrade us it can't make us
worse
oh it's a tightrope the high wire act
well i mean is this really that
incredible then
oh whoops
well we're fine apparently it's okay
it's just a little bird it's still good
yeah yeah sure i love this [ __ ] barn
music that plays
yeah yeah seems awfully fitting for this
moment there you go
this i i think that when they were
making this game they just wanted to
make every experience as
dissonant as possible music visuals
sound the narrative is completely off
yeah exactly
i don't relate to my character at all
yeah okay i just lost my arm for some
reason that's okay
all right great we're here hit that
button i will try
there we go did i do it wait oh i gotta
shut that we gotta shut the door
yeah yeah there we go oh
[Music]
brain
looks like you have no will to live and
you're like oh whatever i mean pretty
much
that's me pretty accurately oh love
everybody
oh i hate where this is heading so to
the bathroom what do you think happens
there
[Music]
okay
wow that is fast wait wait wait i have
an idea okay
i have an idea you know how this is
gonna be easy if we're on the roof
america's a good roof i do i do actually
your wrist is oh no that's perfect yeah
that's perfect
because watch then gravity will do the
rest of the work right
here hey gucci gucci okay okay okay okay
okay all right okay i'm i'm still
holding i think the thing is that
we're not actually supposed to be on
youtube no yeah yeah but it's fine but i
think we got to do this
okay get in here let go oh
see what happened was i thought that you
meant that you just wanted to dodge him
entirely not go back into the
elevator you didn't know it's a whole
frog tongue situation he had going on
okay okay this is what we want this is
what we want uh
is it you're right we can't get in there
you go
yeah uh-huh that's all we need and now
watch okay
when we when we when we get in here i'm
holding on you swing grab i've already
let go
yeah you yeah you go over grab and then
i go over and
no wait grab it grab it grab that get it
out of there
yeah yeah okay good excellent easy
easy easy there yeah easy
i hit it with my nubbin i saw that good
nub thanks
that was excellent dude you were working
out your nubbins dude
thank you for noticing see this flex
yeah
you freaking broke the levator i've been
working out bro
dude how do you get your nubs that big
i've been told it's genetics only
ah steroids babies oh yeah me too
how much no i'm steroids can you get in
the hole
i'm look you think i haven't been trying
my nub just isn't as strong
don't you blow us up not after
going through that [ __ ] hey you got a
hat oh he's
dead we'll keep you warm the night's
dark and full of terrors
up we get
nice do you think we would have gotten
better at just the basic movement by now
nah hello sir what are you doing here
oh my god get off and make it off and
make it happen
being eaten by rats does this open above
us i hope not
all right it does i hope so why not all
right i'm gonna okay we're both
aha can't eat the air get off me
it's gonna have food forever and it just
doesn't want to let go
all right we need to inchworm our way i
think
okay hang on oh we're too thick oh
god can you stop existence already sucks
okay wait i let go i yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh here we go oh yeah this is locomotion
secret is it whispering secret secrets
secret secrets
yeah nice oh god can you stop
are they babies or cats like what oh
my god been never been more terrified
that's fine you never wash that hand
anyway that's okay
jesus christ ah right
my hands are a great sacrifice okay okay
it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's all
good it's all good
it could be worse oh wait i can't even
see anymore yeah don't worry i'm guiding
this
oh my god what happened to your your
your nubbins
who would have thought we could get
worse we are horrifying
we were pretty before but now we're ugly
let's not try and polish a turd here
okay
i think if you polish a turd it might be
marginally better are you
me is it me okay we're both don't let go
that's what's
gonna happen do we need to feed are we
do we eat are we a baby
are we a fully adult like i'm not sure
what just
think about it this way somewhere out
there there's two asses with a set of
legs attached to each other
yeah honestly that game would control
better probably oh god this is [ __ ]
right
excellent i don't think we have a
feeling we
don't want to be there okay we're not
going to swing swung because if we
switch
worm okay i'm an inch me
you me
okay me
me okay classic mark video all me me
thank you thank you thank you me
oh wait i was gonna say if i get rid of
my arm can we swing but i don't think so
yeah you could i think you can scooch a
little more on your
ghost okay i'm gonna and now yeah there
we go that's
uh get rid of yourself
my eyes are closed you've got plunger on
your face i don't think either of us can
see
am i like degenerating because i feel
like my face is melting
yeah you kind of looks like a wax candle
yeah not good
yeah really at the last of its rope
wait what's in here there's something in
there ah you can't open it it's it's a
bunch of crap it's a bunch of bottles
stupid [ __ ]
go go go go now go go
god i don't like that there's time
limits on this game yeah well you know
it wouldn't be a challenge if without
i would love to grab the ground i would
love to i
love the ground oh
my beautiful face it really is like if
you if you delete your arm it really
does give you a momentum boost
what if oh we're not really clear
oh my god oh it's a box there's
my guy raises all rats
you know for the rats how how
yeah i was gonna ask oh there's a hat we
gotta oh
we can't we can't we can't we can't it's
too late oh
my god this is not good
it's fine because watch this
oh you're perfect
okay all right we need to wow okay we're
fine we're fine
hey i'm fine man how damaged could you
be
okay okay okay okay up
right up over there
up and over
okay that momentum really didn't serve
us yeah
i wasn't gonna say anything but okay ah
too late hmm
yeah why are you letting go why are you
allowing me to let go
you know what you're right really the
fault lies with me yeah that's what i
thought
oh oh yeah this is a good idea wait oh
we can swing yeah yeah this is an
incredible idea oh you don't want to
swing too much though and let go
oh god you didn't let go sometimes i
forget whose hand is who
oh oh are we are we boned uh sure
okay okay we're grabbing the hat get it
get it get it get it
get it get it get it get it get that get
that
get that out get that
any minute now and see that no hat
i'm letting go of that hat is
letting go is important okay and holding
on is important too
okay we're just going to let go let go
let go perfect
okay oh perfect i am
so goddamn good and
yeah i'm not grabbed i am not grabbed i
am not grabbed i am not grab i
am grabbed wrong under we go then
oh my god give me give me give me oh my
god
i [ __ ] hate this game and uh
there we go oh it's fine jesus that's
how we do this music is out
what yo why why did you let go what's
the deal with airplane food
what's the deal i would love
oh god we're so beautiful uh-huh
all right what the [ __ ] yo what the [ __ ]
god right
what this is so frustrating oh my god
okay you gotta grab ah wow oh i'm
light-headed
oh my god boom yeah
this is a [ __ ] four dimensional
experience right now my whole body is in
this
yeah uh-huh me too okay here we go okay
it's all okay okay no this is what
happened last time that last one it
curls in there you go
okay we're good we're good keep holding
okay
okay yeah that's good that's good that's
good that's good we're not i highly
doubt we're in the clear
oh my god oh my god oh my god
grab anything i prefer just look man
okay okay don't touch this
no no no no no no not now no i can't
handle that
just give us a checkpoint no way no way
we don't need it we're too good we could
do it all over again
i can't come on oh my god they're
following us
hey that's cool pretty fun video games
are
like awesome
[Music]
you